[Applause]
foreign
researchers are preparing us for a
revolution that will change the world
Forever by looking into the future of
artificial intelligence this revolution
isn't going to happen in a few decades
but in a few years which means that the
clock is ticking for now for businesses
to start embracing AI artificial
intelligence has become a part of our
Lives due to its revolutionary nature
artificial intelligence also faces
numerous debates regarding potential
impacts on individuals although it could
be risky it's also a fantastic
opportunity
it is estimated that the global
artificial intelligence Market will
reach 267 billion dollars by 2027.
people are worrying about losing their
jobs as AI continues to advance because
it has revolutionized Industries across
all sectors but AI has increased the
number of jobs and possibilities
available to individuals across all
Industries every machine needs a person
to run it although AI has replaced
certain occupations it still creates
more jobs for humans
AI can be categorized into three types
firstly weak AI performs specific tasks
like Apple's Siri
General AI performs tasks like a human
the super AI is more capable than a
human but both General Ai and super AI
are hypothetical because these
Technologies are not yet developed and
research is going on however the
development of such AI will take a lot
of time the development of AGI will
accelerate within the following 10 years
in fact according to researchers there
is a 25 probability that by 2023 AI will
resemble humans when it comes to
thinking capacity additionally the
current data boom computer developments
and improvements in automated methods
and machine algorithms will provide a
solid foundation for platforms with
human level ai ai has occupied crucial
sectors like healthcare
cyber security e-commerce agriculture
robotics education the military system
Finance gaming and many more AI is used
in healthcare to identify diseases
helping healthcare service providers and
their patients make better treatment and
lifestyle decisions
we can say that without AI we couldn't
have made the incredible recent
advancements in fields like robotics
virtual reality
chat Bots face recognition
and autonomous vehicles
smart robot advisors in finance
Insurance legal media and journalism
will deliver instantaneous research or
discoveries in the upcoming years it is
anticipated that artificial intelligence
and machine learning will become more
prominent in the consumer Market which
will immediately affect how well web
development functions virtual assistants
or chat Bots will provide professional
advice other advantages include
strengthening governance through better
decision-making processes shortening
time to market for r d initiatives and
streamlining transportation and supply
chain Networks given all these scenarios
AI is all set to revolutionize every
sector in the near future given that it
is expected to impact 60 percent of
firms artificial intelligence will
continue to spread deeper into a wide
range of Industries in the upcoming
years it is currently driving
development in our smart devices cars
and favorite apps in the coming years AI
will invade every aspect of our life and
eventually surpass human intellectual
capacity it won't be long before
artificial intelligence becomes a common
part of our everyday lives
as it becomes more prevalent it will
allow us to live more efficiently and
improve our lives by increasing their
effectiveness efficiency and
concentration on the primary tasks that
require people's attention AI
Technologies are transforming many
industry sectors artificial intelligence
will change the world for the better
thank you for watching please make sure
you subscribe to our Channel and press
the Bell icon to never miss updates from
Simply learn happy learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here